you
[Music]
all right so thank you guys for coming
out hi my background is kind of all over
the place but financial data sets have
been kind of where I've spent most of my
modelling time and that's actually gonna
be the bulk of what I talk about today
we're gonna hit two case studies when I
get more applied
I will not go toe to toe with the great
theoreticians here but hopefully I'll
give you some ideas of what we can take
away don't have here we go so
specifically we are talking about you
may have read this web strike you may
not but basically we at fiddler labs
have been working on explain ability
technologies kind of in a very applied
sense we're trying to productize them
and make them useful to more people and
and easier to use as well as you know
kind of getting away some of the gotchas
or
adding features where we can so today
I'm going to talk about primarily one
major case study which is sort of fair
lending and I will say even though I've
modeled financial data sets I haven't
worked in the regulation space so and
you have please forgive me for making
some abstractions or simplifications and
then we'll also talk about a more
medical case present some other research
that are actually not mine but is
something we've been looking a lot into
at fiddler and so hopefully the goal is
I want I want everyone here to be able
to take away some ideas about explain
ability if you're new to the space
hopefully this would be a great primer
if you've already been in the space
hopefully there will be some nuggets of
wisdom and if you're already practicing
it hopefully there'll be a couple
general use guidelines or things you can
take back to you in practice here we go
okay so really there are two big
takeaways I want to give you guys the
first one is that explanations are kind
of just models in and of themselves and
so if you're used to building models
building explanations is kind of related
more than you'd think and the second one
is that there's a great power to this
idea of global complexity yet local
simplicity when it comes to explaining
complex phenomena that are globally
complex and so hopefully by the end of
this you guys will have a much better
understanding what these are but I want
to put these up first so you can kind of
percolate on it as I talk so to give
some context of why explain ability I
think that's a question I get
and I want to kind of preempt that here
there's some concerns today machine
learning used to be applied to you know
ads or other cases where we can test
really quickly if used to show someone a
stupid ad like it's it doesn't really
affect their life drastically the stakes
are not so high now we're this
technology is maturing it's being
applied more and more to cases where
people really care about the outcomes
discrimination is a big word that's
popped up with AI and unexpected
consequences you know once you push
something into production you're
affecting real people's lives you're
affecting your business's bottom line
and you're doing it in a way that maybe
you want a little bit more trust and
insight into you know there's also legal
backlash now that's that wasn't there
before now here we see a tweet where the
hashtag AI is next to kind of fairness
and and your rights and GDP are so you
know even though GDP per hour is still
being interpreted and developments are
coming out we see that you know you know
I'll have a right to an explanation
whenever there's an automated decision
about you and if a AI is being used in
this automated decision we have to be
able to explain how that is playing its
part so that's a big you know case of
how do we how do we address this may I
explain ability I'm gonna talk now about
the takeaways that hopefully really
break that down further so first year
that what I mean when I say explanations
are models is that when you you know you
have a phenomenon and you're trying to
explain maybe it's a model decision
maybe it's just a real-life phenomenon
that explanation is sort of in the form
of outcome why happened because of some
input features reasons when you have it
X and and then if you're a math person
or you know if you're not this is pretty
simple you know sorry I don't have any
of the probability you know really
complicated Sigma notation today's just
gonna be like simple equations here but
um we see it's kind of y equals f of X
and then here you can read that a
different way you know the way that X
turns into Y is some function there's a
list of rules and so that leads us to
this idea that of course well we just
have to look at the model and
why it's doing what it's doing except
you run into models like this this is a
you know three layer neural network and
if we have any volunteers somebody go
ahead and read this equation here and
you won't want to give me an explanation
of what's going on now so we have these
activation functions on top of
activation functions on top of weighted
sums and of course you can compress this
with tensor notation or linear algebra
notations but at the end of the day then
you know do you really understand the
linear algebra notation in an intuitive
way you know some of us might I
personally have more trouble with that
sometimes it's a practitioner so black
boxes are really just models that have
rules that are so complex that in
inspecting them becomes a challenge in
and of itself and to solve this when we
want to put it into practice we have to
really kind of approaches we can take
the first one is to abandon complex
models or to construct their complexity
in such a way that we can break them
down into smaller pieces each of which
is is meaningful and we can interpret
that piece alone and then kind of
aggregate our interpretations as well as
aggregating the models and really get
that kind of inspection based approach
and that's been I think the predominant
theory of interpretable machine learning
for many years but I think recently
there's also been this other trend
toward can we approximate complex rules
with simpler ones to get a pretty good
understanding of really what's going on
here in a way that's good enough
you know understandable enough and lets
us keep our black box and so you know
these are kind of two different ways I'm
gonna actually spend a lot of this talk
say arguing for black box explain
ability not because it's you know every
case always the best or a practitioner I
use what works but but because there's
some there's some compelling reasons to
go after this and and I think also this
is something that more people would be
better off learning about here because
there are some interesting nuances and
takeaways so you know three big reasons
I have here poor performance potential
for discrimination and in my personal
opinion with no citations here I think
this is just more of a
a human based intuitive way of doing it
so if you go in Kaggle you'll see that
the winning solutions are typically
ensembles using black box models like
boosted tree algorithms and neural
networks and none of those is a simple
interpretable model in and of itself and
so you know this is the playground in
which the most you know powerful most
performant model wins and we don't see a
lot of these simple interpretive models
so there's often a trade-off in terms of
discrimination an overly simplistic
model can kind of depending on your data
set and there's some really interesting
research by Irene Chen on this you can
have if your model has is maybe a line
and you're fitting it through a
nonlinear space you may fit the non
outliers better than the outliers and
sometimes in the real life situations
the outliers are protected classes
they're minorities they're people who
lie away from the typical groups but
should not be treated any differently by
your model so if your model is worse at
you know doing what it does approving
loans giving medical diagnosis
predicting you know criminal recidivism
and it's it's overly fitted to kind of
the majority class there can be some
interesting discriminatory effects that
you don't even realize they're coming in
there so even though you're okay with
sacrificing performance you may run into
other problems and then lastly I'm gonna
kind of give a humorous example of why I
think you know bla bla to explain
ability is sort sort of a human process
how many of you have had those that let
me let me read the pictures here wake up
in the morning alarms ringing and you
have a question for me this is usually
do I want to go out and pick up some
heavy things or do I want to roll over
and kind of take a catnap for another 45
to 60 minutes before I start my day this
is a decision I made quite frequently
almost every morning my alarm goes off I
decide one in the other and you know I
have a vested interest I want to do more
of the bottom choice I would like to be
a healthier person you know eat right do
all these good things so I want to
explain what goes on in my head
when I you know pick the first option I
want to explain those decisions and I
can come up with you know so many
different models there's excuses of
what's driving that behavior I can test
them out and see
if my friends ask I can I can convince
them perfectly you know oh it was rainy
you know I was up late the night before
I still sore from the last time I worked
out but in all those cases there's no
there's no you know MRI imaging there's
no brain scanning going on really
figuring out is that really how Luke's
mental model works you're you're just
kind of fitting something looking at my
behavior looking at every day I do these
things and picking out patterns of okay
when the inputs look like this the
outputs tend to look like that and
that's why and I can come up with some
simple rules too like it's raining I go
to the gym less well is that actually
what's driving my decision or is that
just a very good explanation
I would I would argue that this kind of
black box explain ability has its merits
and so this leads us to kind of another
benefit to this black box explain
ability which is my second takeaway for
the day and this is the idea that you
can be complex in your decision-making
in your model but for a specific
decision for you know for a single
inference of a model you can be quite
simple and to give credit where it's due
this is an image popularized in the
paper that presented the line algorithm
locally interprete Balad elects
planation x' and a lot of these ideas I
think we're first at least popularized
by that work but the basic idea here is
that for let's say we have a single
prediction this is you know your your
loan application was rejected so red is
bad rejection and this is you know input
X 1 and X 2 our model is this this color
so you can see okay for any X 1 X 2
pairs like if we knew the model
perfectly anywhere it's red we're gonna
reject in whereas blue we're gonna
accept it's a nice model it's also not
very linear there's not a clear
explanation of okay if X 1 is you know
created in this amount and X 2 is that
way then you know accept or reject
however around this decision we can draw
this linear line we can we can now say
okay you know around this if you had you
know higher X 1 value you would be
accepted if you had a much you know if
you if you lowered it you'd still be
rejected you know if you're at 2 value
went up or down it probably don't do
anything for you and so we can build
this this local explanation that is kind
of accurate
for that particular example and and
really meaningful and fits the question
you know so this is my rainy-day example
okay if it's not raining maybe there's
other reasons that are sleeping in but
here for rainy days it becomes very
simple we can get a simple explanation
passed it to a person the you know get
everyone on board and have everyone
understanding what's going on so this is
this other you know idea of global
complexity local simplicity sometimes
explanation can be a matter of finding a
local area where we can achieve the
simplicity needed for explanation and so
with that I'm going to jump into our
case study where I'm going to actually
present this this mentality and approach
in the wild today we're going to be
focusing on the idea of loan
applications if you have applied for a
credit card like ever
you fill on a web application you submit
there's a little loading circle and you
get a response almost immediately and
the reason it's so fast is because not a
single person is involved in that
decision what happens is your loan
application gets sent as some sort of
JSON blob to their server they process
out a vector of machine learning
features feed that through some model
that they've already trained and get
back a score in this case it might just
be estimated risk of defaulting on the
loan it's probably much more complicated
maybe multiple scores they have a hand
design set of thresholds but they're
going to look at that score and
automatically make a decision based on
it
to accept or reject so here if you have
a 30% chance of default it was expressed
in probability units here they're going
to go ahead and the lender will reject
this application now I'm in in real life
this is a problem that banks deal with
every day
fair lending laws require lenders to
explain their rejections if you if you
give someone a loan you do not have to
justify yourself at all but if you
reject somebody you have to do you have
to submit justification and reason to be
able to say okay it wasn't because this
person was in a neighborhood a specific
neighborhood and I'm redlining against
them in that neighborhood might be you
know majority minority residents and
there might be some racial disparate
impact no it's rejected because their
credit scores too low or some other
thing that we we've considered fair
so explain
that the model the way the model uses
its inputs is important because if it
uses it in a way that's not not
understandable we have no explanation so
that the other problem with this though
is they can't just come up with a very
simple model because they care about
performance you know the bank makes
their money on having a good credit
model that has a good accuracy if they
accurately predict somebody's risk of
default and they lend to the people have
a low risk of default they're gonna
recoup higher investment returns and
then like I said they have this
requirement they are interpretable and
so we also need a person to build agraja
I understand what the black box is doing
so to set the stage here's some details
when the data set we used it's about
half a million peer-to-peer loans these
were from Lending Club public data that
we've processed to include just features
that were representing information
available at the time of a loan
application and then the target is
whether the outcome was fully paid or
charged off charged off as just a fancy
word for the bank gave up the lender
gave up and they charged it off as a
loss in this data set and these in the
training set there's about 13 and a half
percent charge off rate we have about 50
continuous variables many might be
integers are not so continuous here's
some examples of selected ones you have
the amount of the loan the employment
length of the person their annual income
if you can't read some of the small text
don't worry the the important stuff is
more on the left we have some
categorical features we won hunt and
code those we get a bunch of these
inputs over 100 model inputs and because
we're not in the business of actually
creating lending models we just do them
all into these two different algorithms
training them on 134 indicators and and
looked at the performance so it shows a
simple model a logistic regression a
complex model a great grading boosted
trees model and we observe although it's
hard to tell from this ROC curve that
there is a there's a there's a
significant increase in performance when
you use the more complex model so
there's a trade-off between the
simplicity and the performance of it
specifically I mean you can look here
like let's say the bank is gonna
standing right in front of the light
source this may have a laser pointer
actually anyhow I'm not gonna worry
about that the if you were to accept a
60% false positive rate you know you
might be seeing a percent or two
increase in the true
which is the the rate at which somebody
is being rejected because they're risky
so if we catch one or two percent more
of the people who are going to default
on their loans that cuts you know one or
two percent of our overall costs which
is huge to our bottom line so I found in
mind we're gonna go to the interpret
ability section logistic regression has
built-in global interpretability thanks
to the fact that it's a linear model and
by construction assigns importance from
its weights to each input so here I've
written out in kind of some linear
algebra notation we have log odds of the
event which is a default in this case
nom is equal to a weighted sum of inputs
X and then we put it through this
transform that turns log odds into
probability units and this is a you know
logit link function is responsible for
that or sigmoid and then we see we can
kind of interpret what this model is
learned by looking at the weights so
what is WI well since we standardized
our input which I didn't mention but we
did we can sort of compare the
magnitudes in some wishy-washy
hand-waving way and we can definitely
compare the directionality so we can see
total accounts has a negative waiting so
the higher your total accounts the lower
your log odds are and then when you you
know put it through the sigmoid the
lower your probability is going to be
cuz it's a monotonic transform function
conversely if your debt-to-income ratio
DTI which is the second orange thing
there the higher that goes the more
there's a weighting that weights your
log odds higher and so you have problems
with you know if you have a very high
debt or a very low income that'll show
up as a high DTI and then you're going
to have a the model will assign you a
higher risk it's important to mention
though that you can't just say okay well
if they you know if they pay off some of
their debt then it'll change this much
because that will affect their debt to
income ratio it'll affect for different
measures the different kind of debts
depending on what day gets paid off some
of these other features if they close
out certain rotating revolving balance
accounts that'll change number of open
accounts you know and will also affect
their FICO score which is included here
is the FICO Range midpoint we actually
don't have the exact score we have a
midpoint of a range of scores they're
fallen and so you know there's some some
even with this perfectly interpretable
white box
last box model here the fact that we
have correlation between inputs or
inputs are actually functions of
real-world events because there's
engineered features like debt to income
ratio and the fact that we put it
through this nonlinear transform means
that there's there's a little nuance
that we can kind of get directionality
and maybe magnitude but this has been
good enough in the lending industry
generalized linear models are very
popular these were I don't I don't know
I don't work at a bank they may be doing
something slightly more sophisticated
with monotonically restricted
constrained boosted trees or something
like that but here this monotonic
functionality and the weighting is good
enough to generate very satisfactory
explanations that are stood the test of
time boosted trees to get some sort of
importance waiting we can look at their
you know cumulative information gain
from the training process or some of
these other features people have
proposed counting number of splits by
feature and get a sense of okay like
FICO range midpoint was used a lot to
generate a lot of discernment kind of
reduced the entropy of the prediction
tasks in the base learners of this model
and if all that sounds like gibberish
well it kinda is when it comes to
determining what caused the model to
make a decision and that's what we care
about when we go back here in this
particular case study and this is maybe
a bonus takeaway it actually depends
what you're explaining is how the best
way to explain it is so here we really
care about why they were rejected which
in this particular case we're gonna say
they'll they have a threshold if they're
if they're you know likelihood of
default was above 20% 0.2 and remember
the base rate is about 13 and 5% so if
we predict they're at 20% they're almost
you know they're approaching double the
base likelihood they're they're much
riskier than expected why does the model
think that well that's the the rejection
and we need to explain it okay why the
prediction is significantly above the
average here and so here's here's a case
where you can see logistic regression in
boosted trees predictions is the second
to last two columns or sorry the columns
that are third or less and second to
last and then the actual result and you
know we see that it's it's sort of
calibrated but we really want to you
know dig into this and so with logistic
regression is pretty simple
I actually have a zoomed in version here
so walking through it you can see the
factors we process the factors with one
hot encoding and standardizing so they
become these indicator features that get
fed into this massive linear algebra
that is a logistic regression fit and
then if we multiply the weights that we
saw before on that slide against these
indicators we get some sort of impact
and so we have a base log odds
that's the intercept of the model it's
about negative 2 we run that through our
sigmoid we get about 12% which is very
close to the base you know 13 and a half
percent default rate that makes sense
then when we sum up all of these facts
and it's interesting we can see that you
know the first two thing is the fact
that they're employed for five years and
have a bunch of open accounts actually
contribute very heavily to reducing
their log odds however you know kind of
death by a thousand cuts they have a
bunch of these other pretty high impacts
you know modern impact features that you
know it's a very high low and $22,000
which if you look at the distribution of
all loans most loans and this data set
are much lower than that their FICO
score again not high enough some of
these things they have you know accounts
that are open past 24 months is only 7
euros it's it's got a impact on that
they have 7 it's an you know negative
impact and so you can start to see some
of these things increasing their risk
but as the model we can then just add
the sum of this last column all the way
you know past this is only at the top I
think 10 features we can sum it all up
it comes about 0.75 we add that on we
move from negative 2 to negative about
negative 1 point 2 6 run it through our
sigmoid and we get our point 2 2 out and
so when we explain something we can say
ok well if you were able to raise your
FICO score you would you know have a
decrease the that FICO score impact on
your log odds which would then decrease
your prediction you probably get below
the 0.2 threshold now remember what we
talked about you know things you do to
improve your FICO score might also
change their other features and then you
know that that might add some complexity
but there's sort of an intuitive
breakdown and we can create an
explanation the real question is can we
match this for the boosted trees because
if you just say oh well the future
importance you know FICO score was just
really important think of what do I
change you know how do I get my loan
approved next time we're gonna use
something called added
feature attributions this is a local
modeling technique that kind of brings
in this idea of local simplicity so this
general idea of this this class of
basically linear explanation models
where even though your real model is a
really complicated boosted trees model
remember that explanations are just
models and so we can constrain our
explanation to be of this linear form
where we have some intercept term and
apologize to the Greek this is the
notation used by Scott Lindbergh when he
presented this general class as well as
the shap algorithm or shape I should you
know so we can tell me afterwards the
proper pronunciation but it's from the
Shapley values of game theory about how
to fairly attribute the outcome of a
game the success to the collaborative
players of that game and so if we think
the outcome of this prediction game is
the model prediction or more nuanced the
increase in model prediction over some
baseline then we can attribute that to
all of some set of features and we're
gonna actually pick different features
so we call G this is just our
explanation because explanations are
models and we construct this vector that
might simplify our inputs because
remember we had 134 inputs some where
integers some were continuous variables
we may choose to one hot encoder
categoricals to get that 134 or we might
leave them as categories and so you know
we make some of these decisions when we
train our model we can make different
decisions when we explain it that's a
really cool power of this because even a
logistic regression unlike genomic data
if some sort of linear model can stuff
you know thousands of meaning basically
individually the features don't mean
anything how do you explain that well
you might pick something else for an
image you might choose super pixels and
actually have next slide of a couple
examples of these explanation features
but if we restrict our input one of the
things we can do is make them be binary
so we can say okay we're gonna only
explain in terms of yes or no things so
we can say oh you know this happened
because blank was true or blank was
false that's it makes a nice human
readable explanation and so then this
linear form comes out to be you know the
actual prediction
according to G is there's a typical
prediction that we would expect and then
we add this kind of
for each of the input features that
we're gonna blame it on whereas these
are the the reasons and Phi I is the
blame for reason I and so then I guess
question that comes up is okay well
that's nice this seems like a nice model
you can read it and understand it yes no
questions how do you learn this model
and there are a number of techniques
lime is a technique that learns a linear
model this paper by Scotland Berg and
the tiny font at the bottom you know
presents this shop class as a unifying
framework to unify deep lift some tree
based methods and lime and there you
know more there's more work being done
every day on these so for this
particular case study we used kernel
shop which is presented by Scotland burg
his code and we trained this model by
kind of sampling permutation based and
say oh stay on this line but but I want
to stress that like you know even if the
assumptions underlying shop don't fit
your data and all that I think the idea
of these local explainable models is
really the key takeaway in the important
part so here just to give some some
ideas of what you can explain in terms
of depending on your particular task if
you have structured data you could just
replace for each input if it's a
continuous beat you could just replace
with the mean value or its categorical
clue you could place it with the most
common value another another option is
you could permute a feature a bunch of
times and say okay zi is you know let's
say fico midpoint is the feature I'm
trying to blame things on this applicant
had a FICO score of 700 knowing that
their FICO score was 700 calls the model
to do something what did it cost what is
the blame according to that piece of
information well how do we simulate
removing that information we can permute
it we can run the model with everything
else the same replace 700 with a
different number from another row and
the training sample and we can do more
than one at once because sometimes
features interact we can place subsets
with permutations and average them out
and that's kind of with this kernel shop
function is doing there's a kernel that
weights things to provably with infinite
replacements recover the Shapley
game-theoretic guaranteed values that
are kind of fair
in a game theoretic axiomatic principled
way even if you don't run it infinitely
many times you just get a pretty good
model that's a good explanation for
unstructured data you can do things like
forwards you can do a bag of words model
you can say okay we're gonna blame it on
the vocabulary of this input and even
though in general bag-of-words models
may not be an accurate way to describe
your complicated deep neural network for
a particular input this local model very
simple local model may actually describe
what's going on quite well you know
first particular tweet about climate
change the word climate might be really
important and just being able to say the
word climate was important for this
example is a great explanation of what
the model is doing so we knew that super
pixels for images that sort of thing so
once we've binarized our features here
remember we're doing this absence or
presence of feature I is Zi that we're
explaining and again uh I realized I
made two versions just in case the size
isn't big enough hopefully you all can
see a little bit better here we can run
the model through a bunch of samples on
the training data and see the average
model prediction is about point one four
and at the base rates point one three
five or thirteen and a half percent we
see this sort of makes sense to us so
then for this particular example this is
the same example that the logistic
regression predicted point two two on
here we're getting point two nine nine
about point three the booster trees
really doesn't think we should give this
loan but why well we can attribute blame
to every feature and rather than
worrying about some link function we can
just do in a purely linear way so our
base prediction is point one for our
actual predictions about 0.3 that change
about point 1 6 everyone following me
can be called we just call that to be
via our explanation G the the
decomposition for each of these features
so by running this algorithm we get
blame loan amount has the highest blame
and it really increased the score so if
we didn't know that loan amount was
22,000 we would expect a model to
predict point 0 6 7 less or 0 6 8 I'll
round it here similarly FICO midpoint
and this number of I actually cannot
tell you what what the bc TL is if you
work in find out you might know
those things are also contributing to
the models and a you know confidence
that you are a riskier person than
normal
however there are a couple things that
the model is actually using in your
favor
the high number of accounts as we saw in
the logistic regression booster trees
also likes 39 accounts and things that's
helpful and if you took away that
information you'd expect your your risk
to be you know almost 2 percent higher
in this case so we're able to kind of
blame it on all these things and say ok
if your loan amount was something else
we'd expect an improvement in your score
and there's an explanation we could give
us to the person they're like well I
didn't get the loan but at least I know
what's going on everyone can be sort of
happy and so we had fiddler kind of
taking some of these ideas and trying to
put them in the hands of practitioners
even outside the data science team and
and so you know we you can actually come
up with a more you know interesting user
interface this is some of the work we've
been doing trying to show you how ok we
can give you kind of what if just slide
the sliders around see what happens to
your output when you change the inputs
but also run something like kernel shop
on on your features and and get these
you know linear attributions so you can
see ok accounts open and past 24 months
is really no negative in this case so
looking at that and so that's one way to
do it so but for the case of you know
diversity of examples I'm going to move
into another case study in which maybe
black box explanations is not the best
way and show you kind of some of the
maybe limitations or things to be aware
of when you're applying these methods so
for here we're thinking about model and
heads of medicine so one one example
might be predicting death from pneumonia
or predicting after 30 days whether some
will be readmitted to the hospital and
both of these things pose a significant
risk of what I call correlation is not
causation problems where the model will
learn something that's correlated to the
outcome but that actually human
intuition will flag as not the right
thing to do when they're actually using
the model so if you're going to use a 30
a readmission model to prescribe heavier
treatment to people who are likely to
have a 30 day readmission and lighter
treatment to people who are not you
might start you know you've run into
issues of things that are attributed to
on readmission might be that somebody
has this very severe medical condition
that the hospital is aware of so the
hospital knows you have asthma and you
have pneumonia for example they are
gonna treat you very seriously and
reduce your chance of death
significantly and if our model learns
that oh if you have asked them but
that's a good thing for your you know
chance of survival and we should start
kind of ignoring the people of asthma
sending the outpatient clinics we might
get people killed and so we really need
to understand these models to a deep
fundamental level and and maybe that
kind of wake up in the morning and
decide not go to the gym explanation
case is not going to cut it in here
additionally humans are the ones who are
using these models this is not a
completely automated system you don't
submit an application get an instant
response this is a doctors at the
hospital caring for you and trying to
get extra information using this model
and so our primary goal is human
intelligibility we also care that the
model works because otherwise we just
shouldn't add a model of the equation at
all you know trust in people entirely
but our primary goal is it has to be
able to be used by a human to augment
their current system and so one very
interesting and compelling approach to
this is design I've decomposable you
know add complexity to models without
damaging their interpretability and so
generalized additive models are a really
interesting approach to this and this is
largely publicized in this kdd paper
that I've mentioned the bottom and
slides will be released after this I
believe so if you're you know interested
in this please read the original
research but um basically to explain
what a generalized additive model is
it's a very unpopular deep neural
networks are sexy everyone loves
tensorflow and it does some really cool
things like telling cats and dogs or you
know detecting hot dogs I think that was
a really popular application as well but
here deep neural networks are very hard
to interpret and a lot of the techniques
have a lot of assumptions that I
wouldn't want to trust my life on if I
were in that in the hospital generalized
additive models take a slightly
different approach where they're going
to put a set of activations through a
link function much like a neural network
but instead of stacking layer upon layer
it or doing a simple weighted amount but
with just one layer like a logistic
regression they're gonna learn a bunch
of of functions base functions here
called F that transform a single input
so here this is an example from
pneumonia risk score the H function is
related to some impact on log odds so if
this transform here a common one is the
logit linked function or a sigmoid like
like a logistic regression instead of
being a simple line here like a logistic
regression would be the more you
increase age you linearly increase
pneumonia risk or vice versa we've
learned this you know this nonlinear
function but if you look at this by
itself you can see okay I know
deterministically the impact that
increasing my age will have on the
activation that then gets passed through
this link function to get my odds as Y
which is the the risk of death from
pneumonia in this case so here we can
observe an interesting pattern where the
model is learned okay as you get older
and older and you can also look at where
the data lives in CL okay a lot of the
people in this dataset are in kind of
the 60 to 90 age range in that 60 90 age
range you see this very clear increasing
trend but then once you hit about 90
actually for those you know kind of
people way out in the tail there's
actually a slightly lower increase in
risk and so doctor might be able to
combine some of their knowledge that's
not represented in the data or the
machine learning situation to understand
that so for asthma it's very clear if
you learn a relationship that says more
asthma is better for your chance of
death that's very counterintuitive
because it has most a really bad
complicating factor if you have
pneumonia the doctor can flag that and
go ah I understand we treat people with
asthma very seriously and we improve
their outcomes historically we should
keep doing that even if the model you
know it's telling us because we do that
currently they're not as much risk of
dying so here this is another way of
thinking this is a special case of a GA
M gam is when you have a linear F base
function and that is just purely
logistic regression you can learn these
these functions transforms very well and
there's some also interesting work done
in to learning about interaction term
where you can learn a function on the
interactions and add that to your model
as well for interesting interactions but
here everything decomposes nicely into
these visualizable graphical base
functions and some of the performance
results are very compelling on these
medical data sets I encourage you to
take a look at this this paper if you're
interested in that and so here we see
that you know yes you deploying games
might be a nightmare there's no mature
packages out there that I know of that
are nearer you know what tend to flow
can do with neural networks but in these
particular cases there are other
approaches that matter so with that I'm
going to conclude my two case studies I
hope everyone learned something about
explain ability and thank you I will be
in office hours after can you implement
this generative additive models using
like tensorflow or PI torch by just like
not using the loop with all the layers
you could just implement it simply using
some of the basic constructs yes so how
it basically boils down to how you
parameterize these basis functions f and
then how you kind of bubble that up and
and optimize the goal you know you're
minimizing some lost function over this
entire functional form but you have to
learn these base functions so you could
use actually a neural network of has
many layers you want as each F this
paper I believe actually is a boosted
tree album you know completely black box
but only on this univariate relationship
between F and f of X and then a linear
weighted function which you can linearly
weight intensify you're completely
correct there to my knowledge I have not
seen an implementation of gams in a
tensor library like the flow PI torch
though
Hey so in a lot of the motivations here
you're talking really about sort of the
business maybe less modelers use case
but more the business users use case of
explained ability you know preventing
unfairness and and whatnot how does this
how does it how do end-users kind of
like feel about the current sort of
outputs you have like Shapley values and
sort of these univariate statistics or
you need to go a step further tax reshow
whether the explained ability is
correlated with things like unfairness
or you know other sort of poor poor
situations right yeah that's definitely
there's definitely a nuance question I'm
gonna try and give a quick answer here
and then we can talk you know for hours
about this later that's kind of what
this my company is really focusing on
that question the the end users you know
very application application in one case
you know Facebook just launched why am I
seeing this for their newsfeed because
their users are very concerned about you
things like fake news or algorithms gone
wild and they want to build trust with
the algorithms just by explaining them a
little bit so if they can give
compelling reasons for why stores are
chosen for news feed their their
customers are happy and I'm sure they've
you know tested that in other cases you
know you may you may need you know more
rigorous criteria to evaluate your
explanations and understand if they're
valuable and when it comes to fairness
and unfairness you may actually use
other metrics aside from understanding
models to do that so you know that is
that is something however you you can if
you have an intuition of what's normal
for a model to learn and you look at
what the model has learned and you
compare that and you think the model
might be correlating to some latent
variable them you know protected
attribute or something then that is
something that that explain ability can
help with but you know there there are
there definitely nuances to that
um one question I have is so the FICO
score that it's itself a black box from
when I understand so so one of your
inputs is something that's not interpret
interpret of all itself the
interpretations I've seen that's like
your your account history may affect
your score here but it may has a lot of
ambiguity in it how do you deal with not
having interpretable inputs and then
trying to have an interpol interpretable
output that that relies on that yeah so
this actually is a great you just made a
great pitch for this idea of taking
different explanation features then you
use from model features so FICO scores
probably FICO is looking at a lot of the
same inputs that the model is seeing and
like debt to income ratio a number of
accounts count history some of those
features in making their way
independently into the model next to
FICO score so FICO score might be kind
of redundant actually it might predict
the same things that our overall models
predicting likelihood of you know
defaulting on a loan and so if we choose
to explain and blame the models
prediction on a select set of features
then we can decompose the models
prediction just in terms of things that
we can directly understand now I mean
obviously that if you don't use features
that correspond closely to what you've
fed in your model you know the the
matching nasaw that explanation may be
called into question but there's
definitely a lot of power you can do
with that so if we were to remove FICO
score from mono explanimation it would
be able to show kind of attribute the
models prediction to other features that
probably are correlated to FICO score
and you just pull that out of the
explanation and that's an approach that
can work in this case
[Music]